I'm telling you man you gotta you gotta
learn where you can't have them learning
how to fight with my girl now it's the
best I used to be scared every time my
girl fought this is what I'm not even
lying this is me being very vulnerable
this is what made me hesitate to get
engaged because every time my girl would
get upset how would like meltdown it's
embarrassing but I would honestly like
oh my God my baby's mad what do I do
it's disgusting but it's true now my
girl gets upset and I'm just like this
[ __ ] always mad stop what I'm doing
every time she upset nobody got that
kind of time fine dude just keep
watching the game we're okay cuz I
didn't realize man as a different levels
right like men
emotionally two levels happy mad 99% of
the time happy we're just running around
like like puppies just trotting around
in packs wrestling our friends barking
at [ __ ] same same exact thing 1%
criminal rage pure fury like you've
never seen before women got a hole in
between level and I heard it a million
times never put it together you ever
heard this I'm not mad I'm just upset my
girl used to say that to me and I'd be
like somebody get this [ __ ] up asaurus
this is
girl turns out it is a whole different
thing
happy is here Matt is here upset is
right
women get upset every hour they don't
mean anything you come home late we
never go out your ball smell every hour
is something you cheated on me in a
dream
and the mistake we make as fellows is we
are taught our whole lives suck it up
stop being a [ __ ] no lots to see you
complain so we take all these and we're
just like oh I'll be home at night well
let's go dinner
okay I'll shower again
well you don't realize fellas it builds
the fury built and then eventually after
like a hundred of these you don't get
what the [ __ ] is your problem what you
want the enemy I told you not to take
melatonin them dreams of your fall and
that's where you lose every argument
fellas because the second you take it
here she forgets everything she did here
right and now the conversation flips and
it becomes
[Music]
[Applause]
I just don't know who you are sometimes
I don't even know where that came from I
guess I feel like I'm walking on
eggshells around you and you already
went crazy fellas you can't go back
there you didn't like it she didn't like
it
so now externally you got to be like no
yeah baby you're right
oh yeah I'll work on my temper I'm sorry
you deserve better but internally you're
going crazier than ever you're just like
you you're walking on eggshells remember
when I asked if you were hungry you
thought I was calling you fat definit
chefs
don't know where that came from need a
map [ __ ] I'll show you exactly where it
came from
[Applause]
the County fellas you gotta learn a deal
of set